so I'm on the toilet yeah and I was
taking a craft and the uh I wanted to
read yeah so I take my iPad I have my
iPad it is so I'm sitting there and I've
got my iPad and I've got a whole you
have no I got this Toto and I got the
controls and I got a phone here and I
got a TV and I got a refrigerator I got
a whole technology oh it's amazing it's
like a it's like a studio man on seven
gas stations why not okay so it's just
great and I'm in my glory right but like
an idiot so I'm reading something and I
kind of Lean Forward fast as I'm reading
and it was right in the middle and my
glasses come off I don't know they hit
the iPad and they go between my legs and
they fall into the toilet oh no and I
look down between my legs it hadn't I
hadn't done the courtesy flush yet right
okay oh right so my glasses are there
and it's the and they're lying on it and
by the duty on the duty oh okay but I
figure you know I don't know what I'm
not going to keep these glasses
I've got OCD right so I'm sitting there
and I can't breathe well here so so
here's what happens so here's what
happens so I phoned my wife I say you
got to help me I phone I have a phone
right beside the thing she's downstairs
in the kitchen I go Terry you got to
help me you got to help me she goes
what's wrong I go I don't want to tell
you what's wrong bring me a plastic bag
bring your plastic bag so I figure if
she brings me one of those plastic bags
I'm gonna I'm gonna wrap it around my
hand yeah reach in and get the glasses
to go outside take the plastic bag off
and throw everything the glasses and
everything out that's what I'm gonna do
cursed wait wait wait this is what
happens so I'm sitting there and I'm
hyperventilating a couple minutes goes
by Terry finds the bag right and then
she comes upstairs and she knocked she
knocks on the door I go yeah she goes I
got the bag I get up I get up
there's an automatic [__] flight